it's time to set the scene for the
perfect movie night complete with
colorful custom lighting
i'm britt morin founder and ceo of
brittenco and i've teamed up with dq to
welcome you to fandango's family movie
night
i'm going to show you how to take
everyday materials and turn them into
totally magical lanterns so first let's
talk about materials
you'll need a glass jar like a mason jar
wire
tissue paper a pair of scissors and you
can choose to have adult scissors and
kids scissors if they're
helping you out a paint brush adhesive
and then also a battery operated fairy
light and a battery operated
tea light to get started you can cut out
some fun shapes from tissue paper
and if you want the kids to get involved
you can even let them tear off shapes or
cut their own as well
place your shapes on the jar then brush
a little bit of glue on top of them
to hold them in place allow for a couple
hours of complete drying
now we're going to make your lantern
handle just take your wire wrap it
around a few times
below the lip of your mason jar lid
and then tie it off bring it over just
like this and then you'll tie it off one
more time
on the other side
just twist it so it stays in place
when you're done
to add a little bit more magic just wrap
your fairy lights around
the top part of your lantern and when
you're done
you're gonna tuck the battery pack right
inside
then just toss in a tea light
tada how cute are these perfect for an
indoor or outdoor movie night
kind of like the new dq fall blizzard
menu they're the perfect treats no
matter where you are
thanks for watching and be sure to check
out your local dq for the returning
pumpkin pie blizzard treat and other new
flavors
see you next time
you